Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two. David P.
Here is a caller with a financial question
trying to safeguard their friend. Let's take
a listen to this and then we'll talk about it.
Speaker 5: Hi, David. This is Andy from Milwaukee.
I have a friend, 34 and is from. He's been in
America two years and wants to save for a house.
Beautiful. His idea was to put
all kinds of money in his 401k.
And when he had enough, take it out
and use that money. And something
I tried to explain to him, that's a bad idea
because he would pay a lot in taxes and penalty.
I'm wondering, other than a standard savings
account, would you recommend something else?
Speaker 1: So listen, your instincts are
completely correct. This is not a financial
advice show. Every everybody's individual
situation should be reviewed with a financial
adviser you trust, ideally a fee only financial
adviser. But I do have some background in this. I
do have a master's degree in financial planning.
And so here's my thought on using a 401k for a
down payment. There's a lot of reasons not to do
it. You will owe income tax on the withdrawal. You
may even if it puts you into the next tax bracket,
you may even end up paying more tax on that than
you pay on income. Remember the marginal tax rate?
If you're younger than fifty nine and a half,
you will owe a 10 percent penalty on the
money that you withdraw. You can never repay
the account. And so you lose years of tax free
earnings, which is the whole point of a 401k.
So I would not go in that direction. There's also
the possibility of borrowing against the 401k.
Now, there were some special provisions done
around covid on withdrawals I don't know about.
I'm talking about in a non covid situation, you
can borrow up to fifty thousand dollars or half
the value of the account, whichever is less from
your 401k if you are using it to purchase a house.
But you've got to repay that loan usually
within five years. If you leave the job,
you've got to repay it. There's a bunch of reasons
not to do it. So generally speaking, and this is
not personalized advice, do not use time in the
market, right? Leave the money in the 401k if you
want something better than a savings account for
saving for the down payment. In the short term,
if you're talking about years, you could look
at extremely low cost index funds. Now there is
risk with those the money they can lose value if
the market if you've got a four year time horizon
before you want to do the down payment over
four years, the market could well lose value.
But then you're avoiding a penalty and you
would just pay capital gains on the gains
there. So not specifically tailored to
anybody, but I would be really hesitant
to take money out of a 401k for a house down
payment. I would try to plan ahead and think about
using a different vehicle, if that's the goal.
All right. Just I don't I don't know why people
are even calling me with these questions, but I
feel comfortable talking about it. Always check
with a financial adviser. We have a great bonus
show today. We will talk about the communion
abortion controversy with Joe Biden. We will talk
about Texas Governor Greg Abbott announcing a down
payment on a border wall. What we're back at this.
You've got to hear what's going on. It's bonkers.
And we will also talk about remember that guy,
Ammon Bundy, the anti-government militant who
led the armed takeover of a U.S. wildlife
refuge. That guy is now running for governor
in Idaho. We will talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at Join
Pakman dot com and we'll see you on the bonus show